hey this is presh talwalkar
a square pyramid has base pqrs and
vertex o
each edge has length equal to 20.
calculate the shortest distance along
the outer surface of the pyramid from p
to t
where point t is the midpoint of o r
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's focus on the pyramid
there are essentially two paths we can
take from point p to point t
one path will go along the square base
and then a triangular face
the other path will go along two of the
triangular faces
to calculate the length of each of these
paths we will unfold the pyramid onto a
flat surface
there are two cases to consider
in one case each of the triangular faces
unfolds to a different side of the
square base like the petals of a flower
in the other case
two of the triangular faces are attached
to each other on the same side of the
square base
let's calculate the length of the path
pt in each of these cases
in the first case we want to calculate
the following length which goes from p
to t
notice p and t are points in the plane
so this straight line segment will be
the shortest distance between p and t
this is the point r for reference
to calculate the length of p t we will
construct the following right triangle
since each edge length is equal to 20
and t is the midpoint of or
rt will be equal to 10.
next each triangular face is an
equilateral triangle because all three
sides have the same length
so each of these angles is equal to 60
degrees
we thus have a 30-60-90 right triangle
with a hypotenuse rt equal to 10. so the
shorter leg will be equal to 5 and the
longer leg will be equal to 5 times the
square root of three
to calculate the remaining distance
along this side of the triangle notice
its length is exactly equal to the side
length of the square so it's equal to
twenty
to calculate the remaining distance we
take 20 minus 5 which is equal to 15.
we can thus calculate that pt
is equal to the square root
of the sum of the squares of 15 and the
quantity 20 plus 5 times the square root
of 3.
so in this case pt has a length equal to
the square root of 225 plus 400 plus 200
times the square root of 3 plus 75
we simplify this to get pt is equal to
10 times the square root of the quantity
7 plus 2 times the square root of 3 and
this is approximately equal to 32.348
we'll keep this value in mind and now
let's calculate the length of pt in the
other case
we want to calculate the following
length of pt
this is the vertex o
each edge in this pyramid has a length
equal to 20.
and then
t is along the midpoint so we know that
this length is equal to 10.
each of the triangular faces is an
equilateral triangle
so each of the angles is equal to 60
degrees
we can now calculate the length of pt
using alkashi's law of cosines
the length of pt will be equal to the
square root of 20 squared plus 10
squared minus 2 times 20 times 10 times
the cosine of 120 degrees
we simplify this and we get that pt has
a length equal to 10 times the square
root of 7 which is approximately equal
to 26.458
and this is shorter than the length of
pt in the other case
therefore
the shortest length from p to t
is equal to 10 times the square root of
7 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time